it was
additional degrees of
freedom for gravity
it was part of the gravitational
field okay
and uh so i called it the
non-symmetric gravitational theory
now comes the first acronym ngt
let me just break this down for the
audience quickly so in general
relativity of the two tensor as i was
saying before then you have the
symmetric it's
it's a symmetric tensor but any tensor
can be broken up into symmetric and an
anti-symmetric part you can decompose it
much like you can with coordinates
there's an x and y
or if you know about principle bundles
there's a horizontal vertical part so
you can decompose so you can decompose
and tensor into symmetric and
anti-symmetric part anti-symmetric part
is just zero in the einstein field
equations
typically
and what moffett is working on or was
working on was realizing that this
anti-symmetric part which einstein also
tried to work on is not
doesn't represent electromagnetism
which is why i signed through it out
because he was trying to make it fit
you're like wait maybe it's not
electromagnetism but it's something else
okay and you can correct me if i'm
incorrect
very good perfect okay
um
that's a succinct description
um
so
i published a paper
in physical review
1979
called a new theory of gravitation
what you do is in theoretical physics is
the following
you have an idea
as
richard feynman said you guessed an idea
now i'm going to discuss how we would
look for a new law
in general we look for new law by the
following process first we guess it
then we com
don't let that's really true and okay
you have this idea it takes seconds to
have the idea okay
but then you
have to formulate it in in terms of a
mathematical
system mathematical equations
okay so you do that
and you have to be self-consistent
and then
you have to
test it against experiment
and it's three phases
and
the latter part the third phase is very
important
because you have to know as it's correct
or not experimentally it's physics
you're doing physics not just
mathematics
and
if it's not doesn't fit the data
then
you throw away that guess that idea
and you
start some other idea
or you
quit
and this is how physics is done
so had tried to find some way of
verifying this non-symmetric gravity
through it's not easy
doing experimental gravity physics
physics is difficult
of course i had to agree with einstein's
two of gravity that's the first
necessary
thing to find
is correct if it doesn't agree with
it presently solar experimental data for
example
then this the whole thing is off
so
also there were some
people criticized it too just you have
to have criticism physics is a very
conservative business you do not change
the paradigm in physics unless you
absolutely have to
and it's the paradigm shift is usually
driven by experimental physics some the
presence theory
so-called standard theory by the way i
don't like that i won't stand it but
anyway standard theory
uh doesn't agree with some data
or a theory comes forward that predicts
makes a prediction
and
your theory
fits the data that prediction fits but
the older theory doesn't
this is how physics progresses
and uh
so
also at this point
this was a
1979 so i worked on this 80s 1980s i had
students working on
and
for example i had neil cornish graduate
student
who
was from australia
and
he's now professor
a university of montana
uh
he's found
coy senior professor the
head of a
gravity gravitational
physics group
and um
so we we worked on this and
i had a potential solution
for a black hole which did not have a
horizon
okay
and uh
using your modification we're using this
modified theory a black hole with no
horizon that's right uh cornish applied
for a position at cambridge university
to be a
hawking subsystem stephen hawking's
assistant and he
became his assistant
it's quite a funny story
because uh
as neil told me later
he was sitting in
one of the rooms of the
department of applied mathematics
the silver street cambridge where
hawking was
and uh he's looking at the blackboard at
a blackboard
and he suddenly hears this voice
computer voice
ah so you're neil cornish
so you don't believe in black holes i
believe
that was his first thing
so uh
anyway so uh
so this is the 80s so
i started that then i started doing
particle physics again and left it for a
while
i worked on unified theory again and
with another graduate student david bow
who ended up as a professor simon fraser
university of british columbia he was
chair actually of the department at one
point david ball b-o-l
and also with gabor konstadter
who became professor and dean
of science at the
university of winnipeg in manitoba
uh we worked on
that stuff
but there was no clear experimental
evidence that could prove it
you have to have one piece of experiment
of some some prediction
something that you have in your theory
that cannot be
fitted by the other
theories this is very difficult
this doesn't happen often in physics
maximum's prediction
that light has to move as an
electrically wave
with the speed of light
it's a prediction
which uh
hurts
perhaps the
physicist brought
experimentally to be correct this is a
remarkable result the iraq is the iraq
equation
one of the fundamental equations of
quantum field theory and quantum
mechanics relativistic quantum physics
predicted antimatter
when they went and looked for antimatter
and anderson
caltech found in 1932 this is a an
amazing prediction see
so
this happens a few times in physics
einstein's theory of general relativity
had to pass the solar system experiments
and the bending light of course one
point five seven
or five arc seconds
uh
bending of light by the sun
um
the first
eclipse experiments were not all that
great actually
and time had to go on before we had a
really confirmation of the bending of
light prediction by einstein
and uh the perineal advance of mercury
this is the
uh
the rosetta procession
of mercury's orbit
mercury is the planet closest to the sun
and it presets in the
[ __ ] sort of set of shape
which
confounded newtonian gravity where does
your modified theory come in so i had to
fit all this
with my modified theory
but then
i got interested in dark matter
because
there was beginning to be interest in
the
in the 70s
very roman the strong amount of women
astronomer
and ford uh
colleague
did exp observations of uh
rotation curves of galaxies
if you observe doppler shifts
uh light coming and going blue shifting
richard
and from these observations you can
determine
how fast
stars are moving around in the galaxy
in in a galaxy
and they found with great surprise that
the
stars were moving faster than could be
accounted for by newtonian gravity
the if you plot the rotation curve
of the speed
velocity
vertical axis versus the distance
of the size of the star from the center
are equal to zero radially
then the curve comes up and flattens out
whereas you're touring gravity predicts
that it
should fall off okay and it's quite a
six times
the diff at the difference between the
touring gravity and this flat rotation
curve experimentally observationally is
it's a fact of six
and that's confined to a galaxy
that's what happens in our galaxy and
well the reason i'm saying that is
because we're gravitationally pulled by
some other galaxy so if that curve
extended out
extremely far then we should be spinning
you get back to newtonian gravity and
you must do it as you go out towards
infinity
so so it flattens out and then comes
back down again
so this intrigued me because einstein
gravity
contains newtonian gravity and we
effectively use newtonian gravity for
galaxies because the gravitational field
is weak
all experiments
um
on gravity are for weak gravitational
fields the solar system
is weak gravity
except for
neutron stars
einstein mutant it doesn't work
dark matter
what is this so
in the 70s
that the first
astronomer to
to note this problem was uh she was
ricky
in 1933
swiss astronomer rather century
character he has his name on virtually
every aspect of physics he
did some calculation for
what are called clusters these are
clusters of galaxies not stars
galaxies containing stars and these
clusters are huge
and uh he found that what's by what's
called the variable theorem
that they if you use newtonian gravity
they can't be stable they have to
blow apart
gravity is not sufficiently strong to
maintain
equilibrium stability
so he said well there's got to be extra
matter dark matter
and that's it already 1933
and so on
but no one paid much attention to it
but because of vera ruben and the
problem with the galaxies now things
became serious
and uh more and more attention was paid
to
a stock matter and now
it's
to me
in my opinion one of the major problems
of modern physics
because due to the
standard cosmology which i will get into
uh the standard cosmological model
uh dark matter plays an essential role
85 86 percent of all matter
is dark matter according to
fitting the data
cosmological data
um
so
after decades of effort
and large sums of money
millions billions of dollars
one experiment after another
they've been looking for dark matter
particles
and no one can detect them no one has
detected them
so
what does this mean
um
i tend i call it potentially the modern
ether
because ether was accepted as being
a fact
at the end of the
19th century
beginning of the 20th century it was a
fact
because you had to have electronic waves
move some through some medium
like star moves through
air as a medium
maximum believed in ether
and
and so what does your modified theory of
gravity say about dark matter so i
decided to
uh say that um
that they like this mark of the
anti-symmetric part of my gravity theory
what's the part of gravity
that modifies gravity
without matter you see
because the first modification of
gravity
a serious modification
was isaac newton was uh albert einstein
who modified isaac newton's
gravitational theory published in 18
in 1687 in the precomputer
so i'm modifying einstein okay i mean
that's
einstein is failing
newtonian and einstein are failing they
cannot
describe
this issue without inventing invisible
matter
but
one is always agnostic in physics
if you can find the dark matter
next month
these huge experiments
that are still ongoing
trying to detect what's called wimps
wickedly interacting massive particles
if they find it it fits in and they can
explain the rotation curves of the
galaxies
then forget about modification
einstein's theory gravity is a beautiful
theory
it fits the data
and that's it
but in my opinion they're not going to
detect the dark matter
because it doesn't exist